j'ai décidé
de partir tenter l'aventure à
l'international
je vais continuer ma carrière ici mais
sachez
que je suis appelé à l'étranger mais en
tant qu'animateur ou mannequin
paddle dans un instant dis bonjour
Alexandre ça va mon chéri
on m'a appelé
pour faire
un film non
aux États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je ne rigole pas
[Applaudissements]
j'étais en contact avec le New York
Times
un truc sur moi
de fil en aiguille
j'ai eu un contact qui m'a appelé un
américain
je vous jure que c'est vrai
ils m'ont appelé pour que je fasse c'est
pas un rouleau de ouf c'est 8 jours de
tournage
8 jours de ton âge
8 jours de ton âge elle est Los Angeles
donc vous avez pas été pistonné par Béa
[Rires]
je vous explique
je vais jouer avec une actrice que
j'adore c'est une de mes actrices
préférées
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ils m'ont pris
parce que j'ai des blocs
alors c'est un espèce d'indique
c'est vrai donc français alors ils m'ont
appelé
[Applaudissements]
ça tombe bien vous êtes libre
j'ai donc jusqu'à cette idée pour
devenir bilingue
est incroyable je vous explique
l'histoire
je vous explique l'histoire sur ma vie
que le pitch est très fort et je le
raconte toutes les spectateurs
c'est un gars
le film démarre et c'est un gars je
pense c'est ralphine il a tout perdu ça
veut dire que on le voit il se fait
virer de son job ça meuf tais-toi
là on est dans le cinéma là tais-toi sa
meuf la basée
genre il s'embrouille avec tous ses
potes il est au bout de sa vie et il
essaie de mettre fin à ses jours donc
une fois deux fois trois fois et il n'y
arrive pas parce qu'il a pas le courage
donc il va avoir un pote à lui
qui connaît des voyous c'est toi
et il me dit
trouve-moi un gars un tueur à gage qui
va me tuer parce que
j'y arrive pas moi je lui dis mon frère
je vais te trouver un truc comme ça en
anglais
[Rires]
je trouve le gars et il dit au gars sans
rigoler et donc je lui dis attention
frère le gars c'est un ouf déjà il parle
pas si franc il parle pas anglais il y a
que moi qui peut lui départ
je t'explique le gars je vais te
l'envoyer
je vais lui donner une date et donc là
je lui dis voilà j'ai vu le gars le 30
juin il va tuer c'est sûr et certain là
genre on est en mars donc je lui dis 13
avril mais juin 13 3 mois à vivre on
fait un kiffe on lance le truc et qui
signait un truc et tout avec moi tout ça
on lui donne une première partie de
l'oseille au tueur à gage et il dit
voilà bon je vais me faire tuer et je
lui dis mais attention parce que toi je
te connais tu changes pas d'avis c'est
mort donc je vais dire attention tu
changes pas d'avis il me dit mais tu es
fou ou quoi je changerai jamais d'avis
ici ne change pas d'avis il me tue quoi
qu'il arrive il me tue quoi qu'il arrive
incroyable problème c'est quoi il trouve
là c'est que il trouve la
il tombe amoureux il avait écrit un truc
parce qu'il était un peu scénariste il
appelle il kiffe le film toute sa vie
rien il kiffe sa vie il se réveille un
matin il voit qu'on est le 28 juin il y
a la taille il me reste 2 jours à venir
il essaie de m'appeler je dis frère moi
je peux rien faire pour toi frère ah
vous êtes ça il est parti il va te
ta race
je te dis quoi qu'il arrive il va te
tuer quoi qu'il arrive à tuer donc là le
film il va tout faire pour échapper au
tueur à gage qu'il engagé lui-même
génial
[Applaudissements]
vous avez un agent bien sûr
Michael ben chez moi
il est très il est traiteur caché aussi
là-bas
les gars
je vous dis la vérité demain normalement
j'aurais ressentira Bullock sur le
téléphone
ils m'ont vu
ils m'ont kiffé ils ont dit c'est lui
ils ont craqué physiquement et tout ça
ils ont dit chez lui Sandra Bullock à
l'arrivée elle a dit
[Rires]
des essais
quand même d'accord
parce que moi j'essaie quand même de
essayer de calmer l'autre mais je peux
rien faire pour toi c'est un fou c'est
un fou c'est un fou c'est un fou voilà
les gars magnifique alors vous êtes déjà
dans le rôle alors
je sais pas ils m'ont dit cet été
d'accord j'ai dit moi de son l'été je
suis là problématique
là-haut
je veux la voir et je l'aurai la mairie
donc les chéris
je suis heureux
aussi les rôles s'enchaînent vous nous
abandonnez ou vous revenez quand même
ça va non mais je sens que raffine même
bien parce qu'il a envie de faire des
duos quoi on avait rencontré non mais je
le sens
américain je connais pas
[Applaudissements]
j'y connais pas
non mais sérieux
[Applaudissements]
bon les chéris je vous ai fait un gros
mytho personnellement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout inventé le film rien n'est
vrai
c'est possible
vous avez raison
[Rires]
fort ou pas